hurricane Harvey hits Houston and the
fallout is pretty devastating we'll talk
about that plus an Tifa goes back to
Berkeley and we'll talk about that as
well plus the VMAs decide to hit Trump
because of course they do I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show all
right so Watson news breaking over the
weekend most of it from Houston where
hurricane Harvey has hit incredibly hard
apparently there's 50 inches of rain in
in Houston which is just an astonishing
amount of rain and these pictures are
just amazing honor to show you some
pictures in just a second of what the
hurricane actually looks like what the
conditions on the ground have been but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at texture calm so if
you're an information junkie the way
that I am if you need the information
all the time then texture calm is the
best way to get that information texture
calm is an app that allows you to
download and have available hundreds of
magazines at a finger as a touch it is
amazing ok so for $9.99 a month you're
getting 200 plus magazines the New York
our time the Atlantic Vanity Fair
Reader's Digest Sports Illustrated all
of your favorite magazines for $9.99 a
month right now if you go to texture
comm slash Ben you get a 14-day free
trial so you can check it out it's the
way that I read all of my magazines you
don't have to print out all the
magazines or have them stacked up in
your bathroom anymore and I can just
have them on your phone on your computer
anytime you want you can check all the
back issues as well texture comm is
offering my listeners that 14-day free
trial when you go to texture comm slash
Ben that is texture comm slash Ben again
it doesn't matter what you're interested
in they've got a magazine on it
everything from ESPN magazine to Field &
Stream to Food Network Magazine to
Glamour so it doesn't matter what you're
interested in they will have something
for you and $4.99 $9.99 a month get all
of them right get access to all of these
things so you're never going to be bored
again because of texture dot-com and
that you will always have access to the
latest information and in-depth articles
you know long form journalism is sort of
going away on the web but it isn't going
away in magazines you just don't want to
have to pay five bucks a month to each
one of these publications I mean if you
assume five bucks a month for 200
publications talking on a thousand
dollars a month and sitting in for 10
bucks a month so pretty amazing stuff
right there so make sure that you head
over to texture comm slash Ben and check
get out okay so over in Houston it is
full-scale disaster area I want to show
you some of the pictures of what's
happening in Houston really incredible
so this is what certain parts of Texas
now look like you can see the entire
town is covered in water there are a few
cars on the street but you can see that
the cars are covered all the way up to
the windshield so this water is three
four feet deep you're seeing boats with
the with the fan motors on the back just
going around in the streets in this
particular photo really shocking an
incredible photo you can see some more
of it so here's here's another picture
of the this is downtown Houston its
entire it's a lake it's a lake I mean
downtown Houston is entirely underwater
Houston is built in an area that is but
that is about 35 to 40 to 40 feet above
sea level but it is incredibly flat and
there are a few marshes with a club I
use that are over there where all the
water was designed to flow one of the
things that's happened people are
looking at the streets and saying why
are the streets underwater well that's
because the streets were actually
designed as a secondary spillway in case
of situations like this the idea was
that the water would go into the streets
so that wouldn't go into your homes but
it's been completely overwhelmed here's
another picture of what it looks like in
Houston today this of course is a small
child in his home and this kid was
rescued by the way the kid is a sitting
on the counter and you can see this
yellow brine just rising in the kitchen
I got to be two feet high in the kitchen
but there was tape of people who are
actually fishing inside their home
because there's so much water there
legitimately just standing in thigh-deep
water and pulling fish out of their
house I mean totally crazy stuff you can
see water what it looks like when it
pours into an office building this was
happening in downtown Houston as well I
can see the doors are shut it's not
stopping the water here it goes at the
the news headquarters
it is the New York Times News
headquarters I believe
just unbelievable stuff
so some of the questions that people
were asking is they were asking why is
it that Houston was not evacuated so the
governor Greg Abbott wanted to evacuate
Houston about three days in advance the
mayor said no it's not quite as simple
as the mayor's an idiot the fact is that
during Hurricane Rita there was an
attempt to evacuate and like a hundred
people died I believe during Hurricane
Rita in the evacuation because people
were stuck on the roads it was it was
crowded it was overheated people were
dying in their cars and so what would
have happened if everybody had been on
the road and then the flood hits you can
actually look at what the video looks
like of the streets themselves look at
these boats maneuvering down the street
okay this is actually in Dickinson Texas
is what the streets look like right now
you can see there are cars that are
completely submerged and people are
moving around in their boats trying to
save people from their homes there is an
old-age home actually where they had to
save 15 people where the the the old-age
home was completely under water just
incredible stuff so one of the questions
that's been asked is how is Trump doing
on all this right how's the federal
government doing on all this so Trump as
is Trump's want tweets out a lot of
stupid things right he tweets out a lot
of dumb things he tweeted out a bunch of
things about the hurricane that are
really kind of silly he tweeted a it
sounds like a game show host tweeting
about the hurricane you know he tweeted
out for example Wow exclamation point
right about the about the size of the
hurricane I mean it almost as though
like this this 17 hours ago all caps
historic rainfall in Houston and all
over Texas flutter' unprecedented and
more rain coming coming spirit of the
people is incredible Thanks and then he
tweeted also he did a bunch of things
about Mexico and now he tweeted that he
tweeted this this was yesterday
Wow now experts are calling Harvey a
once in a 500-year flood exclamation
point we have an all-out effort going
and going well and he also tweeted out
many people are now saying this is the
worst storm hurricane they have ever
seen good news is that we have great
talent on the ground so I mean this sort
of wonderment from Trump is not is not
good tactics I mean she's not great
politics you don't really want to spend
a lot of time when in the middle of a
storm talking about wow this is historic
like we can all observe this but we're
not in control of it like theoretically
you should actually be projecting a
sense of calm when you do this not wow
look at that rain and that amazing also
we're here so
that's really been the only criticism of
Trump which demonstrates that Trump
actually is doing a pretty good job with
all of this right Trump has not done
anything wrong so the media can you
imagine if Trump were doing a bad job
remember how the media was about
Hurricane Katrina where wasn't even the
federal government's responsibility to
be there and they responded in
relatively prompt fashion and the media
ripped them up and down because the
Democratic governor of the state
Kathleen Mary Landrieu I think it was at
the time she was Tara Kathleen Blanco
was the governor of the state of time
she was garbage she was a terrible
governor at the time and Mayor Ray Nagin
of New Orleans had told people not to
evacuate and then a lot of people died
because of that and then they blame Bush
for it can you imagine if things went
wrong in Texas how much blame Trump
would get it would be insane right the
media would never stop immediate never
stop but Trump hasn't done a bad job
with this because he allowed his
administrators to do what they had to do
he told them to get down the federal
government learned its job from
Hurricane Katrina they're never going to
be caught off guard on this sort of
stuff again and and you know the federal
government is doing what it's supposed
to do here Greg Abbott said Trump has
already told us whatever we need we're
gonna get by the way to all locals in
the state that's really doing most of
this work the National Guard is down
there helping out too but this is the
difference between Greg Abbott doing a
good job at the state level and the
mayor of Houston apparently doing a good
job with local law enforcement he's
Democrats this is bipartisan thing
here's Greg Abbott talking about the
federal government's response what can
you tell us about President Trump's
personal engagement in this problem and
in managing the response to it it's been
extremely professional very helpful he
called and said governor whatever you
need you've got and this is the quickest
turnaround I've ever seen from the time
that a governor made a disaster
declaration to getting that granted okay
so Trump is doing what he's supposed to
do he's what he's checking all the boxes
and the FEMA administrator right works
for Trump says listen we're gonna be
there for years and that's okay we're
gonna fix all this stuff the National
Weather Service says that parts of Texas
might be uninhabitable for weeks even
potentially months after the hurricane
are you prepared is FEMA prepared to be
there for months on end FEMA is gonna be
there for years sir this disaster
recovery this this disaster is gonna be
a landmark event and we're already in
the stages while we're focused on
response right now in help in Texas
you know respond we're already pushing
forward recovery housing teams we're
already pushing forward forces to be on
the ground to implement national flood
insurance program policies as well and
doing the inspections that we need so
we're setting it up and gearing up for
the next couple of years okay again the
point here is that the media would be
all up in Trump's business if Trump were
doing a bad job on this and that's how
you can tell when Trump is doing
something okay when the media are all up
in Trump's business over something
ancillary that means that the main job
that he's doing is basically okay when
Trump does something terrible the media
are all over him when he does something
mediocre the media are all over him when
they're focusing on his tweets about the
hurricane as opposed to the actual
federal government response that means
the federal government is doing what it
needs to do and I promise you the people
in Houston don't give two damns about
what Trump tweets about this stuff all
they care about right now is is there
gonna be somebody who's gonna help me
get out of my house
I mean I was getting so bad that people
were tweeting their home address over
over Twitter to the emergency response
teams because the 911 call center was
Jam they've been over a hundred rest
sorry a thousand rescue attempts I think
five people dead in the flooding so far
in Houston the local PD was telling
people if you're gonna take shelter in
your attic and make sure that you have
an axe because if the water rises you
may have to bust your way through the
roof okay that's how bad things have
gotten in Houston good for the local
administrators and good for the police
and good for the citizens there been a
lot of citizens great stories citizens
out there in their boats dry you know
going around saving people just normal
people I mean just going around there
really it shows the American spirit it
is amazing how the media covers this by
the way there was one guy who was
driving around in his he was sailing
around in his boat picking people up and
he happened to have a confederate flag
on the back of his boat and the media
had coverage of this and they refused to
cover it because he had a confederate
flag because clearly this guy was a
brutal vicious racist even though he was
saving black people from their houses to
clothe the Confederate flag Trump's the
fact that he's out there saving people
anyone with a confederate flag must be
evil and nasty I know there was a story
like that today where there was tape of
it was kind of funny tape of a fellow
who had a hawk land in the middle of his
car and the hawk came in and landed in
the middle of his truck because it had
no other place to land and naturally the
internet went nuts because this guy had
a
a Confederate flag in his car so
obviously that's that's something
terrible and we can never ever ever say
nice things about anyone who has
confederate flag in their car the reason
that I bring that up is because there's
a lot of talk as this hurricane is
happening about why can't America just
be that
why can't America just be that why can't
America just be the place where we all
help each other out where disasters
happen it doesn't matter our political
Creed's it doesn't matter
our ethnicities it doesn't matter our
culture all the matters is that we know
each other and we try to help each other
out because this is America where we're
all Americans but I can't we be like
that all the time well I'm gonna explain
to you why we can't be like that all the
time because we're gonna shift focus to
Berkeley in just a second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Zeile so right now are you
stressed do you need a massage Zeile can
make that happen for you don't have to
wait in line at the at the spa you don't
have to make an appointment days in
advance instead you go to Zeile calm and
that allows you to actually bring them
as suits to your home licensed masseuse
comes directly to you right there
they're all vetted they're all licensed
they're all terrific they bring the
table with them they bring the the
massage oils they bring the music they
bring the whole deal it comes right to
your house it turns your house into a
spa that's what Zeile calm is there for
and they have 9,000 licensed massage
therapists all over the country so you
can get these people to your house in an
hour or less in some cases we've used it
for me for my wife for my parents we've
used it for my sister and who lives on
the East Coast we've used it for my for
my mother-in-law we've used legitimately
everyone my family has now use eel
because it's super convenient and they
do a wonderful job right now to help get
you started our listeners get twenty
five dollars off their first massage by
using the promo code been at checkout so
when you go to zeals EEE Elcom promo
code been at checkout you get 25 bucks
off your first massage and if you sign
up for their massage membership you get
20% off all your massages plus you get a
free massage table and sheet set which
is a three hundred and eighty dollar
value for free when you get that massage
membership there's no initiation fee to
join the membership just a terrific
additional savings on top of the $25
discount you're gonna get when you use
it that promo code Ben I know that I've
been stressed I'm sure you've been
stressed too the news is very stressful
these days Zeile calms EE
L calm can help you out with that use
that promo code Ben did when when you
check out make sure you click on the
link that says
and use that promo code you get $25 off
it'll make your life better I've said
many times that one of the great things
in life is not having to be rich but
actually to feel like you're rich - you
live like you're rich is one of those
things that makes you feel rich without
spending a whole hell of a lot of money
and you don't have to wait in line and
go to some spa they've never heard of
with a weird name instead the person
comes direct your home they're all
licensed and they're all wonderful so
zeal calm ceal calm and use promo code
banana checkout so why can't everything
be like Houston why can't we all just
get along as Rodney King might put it
the answer is because it's one thing to
look at existential threats like the
rain and say okay we all better get
together against it we'd better get
together against this you know I don't
talk Game of Thrones on the show too
much because I know that a lot of people
don't watch Game of Thrones but this is
sort of the general tenor of Game of
Thrones is that there's a threat that
comes from the north it's not giving
anything away there's it's in the first
episode there's a threat coming from the
north and it's these zombies basically
coming from the north for the country
and then in the south of the country
everybody is fighting over domination
and so half of the series is about how
do you get all of these people together
to stop fighting in petty fashion with
each other in order to fight the white
walkers who are coming from the north
Ronald Reagan used to say this all the
time about the Soviet Union used to say
you know we're fighting the Soviet Union
right now they're fighting us
but what if aliens were to come from
outer space and attack the earth well
then we'd all be on the same side
wouldn't we were all human okay but the
thing is that the conflicts that we have
with each other still matter so I know
that everybody wants to do this kumbaya
moment over Houston oh look how
everybody's getting along but I promise
you as soon as the waters recede or go
right back to politics as usual because
these issues matter the question is how
do we all get on the same page about the
issues that matter not just about
opposing the rain all right not just
about opposing the zombies not just
about opposing the aliens but on the
issues that matter how do we all get on
the same page well I would suggest that
the first place to start is we should
all be on the same page about you don't
get to hit people who disagree with you
okay this is the first rule of being a
civilized human being you don't get to
hit people who disagree with you this is
what I'm trying to teach my three and a
half year old right now you don't get to
hit people who disagree with you right
she's gonna get that message now when
she's three and a half not when she's 25
but the left refuses to get this message
so over in Berkeley
there was a s they call it Patriot
prides it's just a right-wing March no
evidence that this is a Nazi March or an
all right mark
as far as I'm aware of this seems like
any it's patriot prayers what they call
themselves now this is a normal
right-wing conservative group and they
were just marching for free speech and
aunt Eva showed up in force and
apparently was pretty horrifying not
just because of what happened but also
because of the police response so this
rally was supposed to happen in a park
and Tifa showed up thousands of them
showed up and the police were supposed
to be guarding the park and the police
themselves said we backed off that all
these people showed up and we thought
that it would facilitate conflict to
create more conflict if we were to try
and get in the way of these mt4 people
so we decided to back off instead they
left vulnerable citizens vulnerable
here's what some of the Santee fam are
she looks like in Berkeley yesterday
so you can see the red flags and the
black flags you can see everybody's got
their face covered good indicator by the
way that if you have to cover your face
or criminal or would be criminal okay so
you can see that they're they're
carrying basically the red and black is
communism and anarchism as that's what
that combination is they're all wearing
black they're all covering their faces
just like a bank robber if you cover
your face it's not because you're about
to do something good when is the last
time aside from Batman no one covers
their face to do something good okay
everyone who does good things once
credit for it everyone who does bad
things is robbing a bank so all these
people are there not to do something
good but to but to march in solidarity
with people who hurt people there was a
journalist for the San Francisco
Chronicle and this just goes to show you
how insane the press are so she's
tweeting from this rally about the
violent things that are going on then
after she said it was mostly peaceful I
love how this works so when white
supremacists
have a rally in Charlottesville and a
white supremacist kills one person in
interest 19 others with a car and a few
fights happen but they're like a
thousand of them then it's a totally
violent rally but when a bunch of people
get violent identify rally it's mostly
peaceful that's the way that it works
when there's a tea party rally which no
violence occurs they are called
terrorists by Barack Obama and members
of the federal government okay here is
my view if a large percentage of your
crowd or even a relatively small
percentage of your crowd is engaging in
violence and everyone else is not
disassociating it is not fair to it is
not unfair to say that this is a violent
movement okay if I were to rally and
people there started getting violent you
know what I would do I would leave or I
would tell the cops to stop the violence
immediately but that's not what happened
here's an TFI actually attacking a
journalist that guy's a journalism they
grabbed his camera and they started
going after him
[Music]
and there's a journalist who's been
pushed down on the ground and and you
can say what was hilarious about this is
people holding up shields that say no
hate on them as they're basically
running people over that was not the
only situation like this here's an Tifa
at this rally in Berkeley attacking a
father and a son they're happening on
this guy beating the crap out of him
just grin folks these are it's just like
it's just like world war two you
remember we were told like two weeks ago
that these people were basically just
like the world war two soldiers right I
mean this is Normandy this is what
Normandy was like Normandy was a bunch
of Schmucks beating up a bunch of randos
who are walking around that's exactly
what Normandy was I don't know why you
guys don't know your history hey here's
another one okay this is this guy was
walking along the street there are
people who are saying is the left was
saying he's an apparent alt writer again
no evidence of who this guy is we have
no clue who he is somebody else was
saying here's a guy walking home from
the grocery store who was attacked
because he was mistaken for an alt
writer we just don't know the answer but
regardless unless he initiated the
violence does this look like appropriate
behavior hey you can see there's a guy
on the ground
- this guy's credit there's a black guy
who jumped on top of him and he's trying
prevent people from hitting him but the
guy goes down and people are beating him
up you can see the folks in the in the
black masks trying to I get violent with
him okay the worst one is this one
you're about to see a guy legitimate Lee
get be pretty senseless here's a here's
a fellow who got jumped on and pummeled
this is 11
and you see there's that guy on the
ground they're dragging him
they're kicking him they're punching him
pretty astonishing so all this stuff was
happening where were the cops for any of
this you see any cops so here's the deal
Berkeley okay let's start with this
I'm coming September 14th we just paid
$15,000 security fee so that you guys
would be protecting if this goes down
it's all on you I've already openly
called and I will continue to call for
no one who is a supporter of mine to
engage in violence even defensive
violence I want everybody to come and be
entirely peaceful okay this is an act of
nonviolent resistance we're going there
with the approval of the Berkeley
administration we have every right to be
there you have every right to be there
you have every right to attend hey don't
act violent because I want the world to
know I want America to see whether the
police are going to do their jobs they
charged us an arm and a leg to ensure
security let's see if they run away and
allow NC 4 to have its way I'm not
blaming the individual cops I think the
cops want to do their job but whoever
the higher-ups here are they're doing a
garbage job and if Governor Jerry Brown
won't call out the National Guard to
stop this sort of material and he is a
horrible governor he is a horrible
governor by the way but if you won't do
that then it's just a monster above the
fact that the left uses the rioters veto
to try and establish these fascist safe
spaces and places like Berkeley so you
wonder you look at Houston which is the
best that we have to offer and then you
look at ante foe which is the worst that
we have to offer you wonder what's the
difference and the difference is then
when there is no existential crisis
people sometimes get worse when there's
no existential crisis people find it's
something to believe in and we have a
country where people have been told for
two generations now that America is not
a thing to believe in that free speech
is not a thing to believe in because who
knows you may be a Nazi who say that the
regime is a white supremacist regime
America is a white supremacist country
there's nothing to defend there's
nothing to stand up for our history is
replete with racism and sexism and
bigotry when you teach people that
what's the existential threat the
existential threat is the system itself
that when you look at Houston the
existential threat is not the system the
existential threat is the rain for Game
of Thrones fans the existential threat
is death right and even if you're gonna
lose you still have to fight but there's
the existential threat but what happens
when that existential threat no longer
exists I think there's a very strong
case to be made
that one of the great ills that happens
to the soul of America it's a great
thing for the world one of the great
ills that happens to the soul of
Americans is the fall of the Soviet
Union not because the Soviet Union was a
great place it was an evil evil place it
was an amazing thing for the world the
Soviet Union fell amazing thing millions
of people were freed and were lifted out
of poverty by capitalism but for the
soul of Americans the idea that there's
this existential threat in the form of
an evil ideology once that goes away we
begin to eat our own what's the new
existential threat that you are going to
devote your life to fighting religious
people we devote our life to fighting
the existential threat of the darkness
right the idea of being a religious
human being in Western civilization is
that you devote yourself to fighting off
the threat of people who are intent on
ripping away the notion of a God filled
universe for your actions matter right
that's what religion is all about is you
spreading the word that your actions
matter that your soul matters that God
cares about you and that the universe
has a mission for you right that's what
religion is about so religious people
spend their life fighting that sometimes
it gets violent in terrible ways but
that's at least their goal right what is
the goal of an Tifa presumably they
would say their goal is to fight racism
but where do they turn their ire they
turn their ire against the common man
walking down the street in favor of free
speech because free speech is just part
of the strata of the stratification of
American society it's a power of a power
structure there's legitimately with the
left set the left will say that free
speech is just the the re the
revivification of the power structure
it's just the reinstatement of the power
structure then the only people will care
about free speech for the powerful the
powerless people don't really have power
of free speech because the poor so we
have to silence people so here's what I
suggest if we all want to get together
again we have to understand that the
existential threat is not without is
within it is not people so much as it is
ideology okay the existential threat
that we now face in the United States is
a nihilistic a nihilistic view of the
universe that says that the new wars we
have to fight our wars against
liberalism itself I mean classical
liberalism against freedom freedom
itself is a threat that is the
existential threat to the United States
what you're seeing in Antigua is in
existential threats to the future of the
country because what you're looking at
right now are people who are willing to
use violence even the Washington Post
got this right even the Washington Post
said antiva
ante
rioters beat up nonviolent protesters
peaceful protesters at least the
Washington Post got that right them
blabbing wrongly about this for weeks
and months the existential threat to the
country lies within it's not just the
rain in Houston it's the it's the
darkness in the human heart that says if
you disagree with me I get to shut you
down hey that's that is a serious
problem again the the tradition of
Liberty Rises out of a judeo-christian
value system that must be reinforced at
every turn for children particularly but
we're fighting that too the existential
threat comes from our own hearts and
that's a much harder thing to fight it's
a much harder thing to fight that's why
conflicts like this aren't gonna
continue to rage and we won't all just
be houston because we're not all gonna
have to deal with our hurricane every
day but we have to deal with the
darkness inherent in the human heart and
that's much harder to deal with it means
looking at ourselves it means fighting
ourselves when we think that we're doing
the wrong thing means contemplating
whether we're living up to our own
ideals and it means fighting people who
are willing to twist those ideals into
unrecognizable forms okay so I want to
talk about a couple of things that
happened over the weekend in the Trump
administration but for that you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wired.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to Daley wire.com that
gets you the rest of this show live it's
a video show not just an audio show and
that means they get to see the rest of
the show live be part of the mailbag
which we do on Fridays here it means
they get to see Andrew Clemens show live
which starts in about an hour you get to
see Michael Knowles's show live that's
about 12:30 and yet see the entirety of
it when we post all of those shows later
you get to watch them without the ads so
ad free experience get Ad free website
as well and if you get the annual
subscription you get all of those things
plus the finest of all tumblers leftist
tears hot or cold tumblr will take you
through many a dark day as tyrion says
his job is to drink and know things this
is your job as well so you may as well
drink from a fantastic tumbler and know
things from listening to the show so you
can do all of those things for a $99
annual subscription which save you money
on the monthly subscription go over and
check it out at daily wire com
if you're gonna listen later go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud please hit
subscribe please leave us a review we
always appreciate it it helps us with
with the rankings on iTunes and it helps
us continue to be the fastest-growing
and largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so the hurricane coverage in the antifa
coverage has has really swamped some
pretty big news that happened over the
weekend a couple of big things happen
over the weekend late Friday afternoon
President Trump decided that it was
definitely necessary for him to pardon
Sheriff Joe Arpaio this was obviously a
political move we can talk about the
ramifications of it why I think some
people are overstating the case against
the pardon but you know it's obviously a
political move you know Juan Williams
sums up sort of the left view of why
Sheriff Joe was pardoned sheriff jumped
a longtime Trump supporter no question
that that had something to do with all
of this here's Juan Williams suggesting
why he was pardoned she's not an act of
mercy for someone who had been denied
justice Sheriff Arpaio has not been
sentenced yet he's been convicted but
not sentenced so this was a pre-emptive
act by President Trump that I think then
sets a precedent going in that he can
act in terms of pardons with little
review from the Justice Department to
help out someone who's a family member
someone who's a political ally this you
remember our pile was not only an early
supporter Donald Trump he was an early
birth er and he is the face of hostility
towards immigrants specifically the
Mexicans and Latinos in this country so
it was an a political act that he
promised his base on Tuesday night at
that rally in Phoenix and he has
delivered on that promise in such a way
as to say that in the future such acts
of pardon are not more normal okay so
what the left is afraid of is that our
piyo is going to lead to a series of
pardons for family members or Trump
pardoning himself you know again I think
that's overstated I don't think there's
a lot of evidence of that I think that
Trump just likes our Payoh and wanted to
pardon him I think it's that simple and
the reason he likes Arpaio is because
our bio says that he likes Trump here is
jarba Sheriff Joe talking about how he's
going to be with Trump until the very
end I'd love that president he supports
law enforcement and I very humble if you
recall two years ago I supported him and
I said publicly recently pardon or no
pardon I will be with it to the end okay
so that's really I think a reason behind
this so let me give you sort of the
background of facts about
Sheriff Joe so you know what you're
talking about so a lot of people are
pointing out that Sheriff Joe has acted
in corrupt fashion that he's gone after
journalists he had to pay on I think a
3.5 million payout the Sheriff's
Department had a power to pay out to
journalists who was wrongly arrested or
harassed by the police they've had to
pay tens of millions of dollars in
various fees for racial profiling in
civil suits so Sheriff Joe has not been
I think a wonderful sheriff he's popular
because for many years there was a lot
of publicity around things like him
forcing inmates to wear pink underwear
because he wanted to emasculate them
which is funny right or Sheriff Joe
wanting them to work on chain gangs
because he didn't want them lazing
around all day and forcing them to live
in tents to be very uncomfortable
instead of being in positions where they
were in prisons watching TV so that he
was popular on the right for a lot of
those things he was also popular on the
right because he would do immigration
enforcement that a lot of people on the
right felt the federal government was
not doing that he would police
immigration that he would do sort of
these immigration sweeps and then check
people the courts came in when they said
what you're doing is illegal it's racial
profiling he defied the courts and he
said I am NOT going to pay attention to
your court orders at which point he was
arrested and convicted for criminal
contempt so there's a couple issues that
are wrapped up here a lot of people are
saying he deserves to be in jail because
of all the things that he did that he
wasn't convicted for okay that's not how
the system works okay if you were gonna
be convicted for those things then he
should be convicted for those things you
cannot like him for those things I think
that's perfectly fine and fair but if
we're gonna talk about what he's being
pardoned of you have to talk about the
crime that he actually committed which
is criminal contempt of court so let's
start with the basic idea of criminal
contempt of court we'll talk about the
politics and wag why it's you know why
Trump did what he did and whether it's
smart or not in a second but criminal
contempt of court is essentially a
political offense I say that it's a
political offense because the fact is
that it is the court basically declaring
that you are not acting in accordance
with its rulings and therefore it's
going to throw you into jail a lot of
people say that this is perfectly
appropriate that if you pardon that if
you pardon somebody like Arpaio what
you're really saying is that the
executive branch has priority over the
judicial branch okay but when it comes
to pardons the executive branch does
have priority of the over the judicial
branch mean that's in the Constitution
Trump didn't do anything extra
constitutional here and if you were to
change the situation let's say that
there was a court in 1960's Alabama that
ruled that Martin Luther King had to go
to jail and so Martin Luther King goes
to jail and then he says you know what
I'm not showing up for jail I mean I'd
rather be held in criminal contempt or
they convict him of something and he
wants to they say you have to pay a fine
because you're disturbing the peace
right I'm making the situation up when
Martin Luther King says I'm not paying a
fine the law is unfair it goes screw
yourselves and then they throw him in
jail for criminal contempt and then he's
pardoned by LBJ is that illegitimate
it's not eligible under those
circumstances so simply saying that any
attempt to overthrow a criminal contempt
conviction with a pardon is illegitimate
I think is over broad so the question
becomes was this a political conviction
of Sheriff Joe so there's a guy named
Warren Henry over at the Federalists who
has a very very good column about this
today explaining all of the all of the
background to this he talks about the I
should really just read some of it
because it gives you the factual
background you need in 2007 Manuel
DeJesus Ortega Melendez and other
plaintiffs brought a class action
against Arpaio the the Maricopa County
Sheriff's Office and other defendants
alleging the defendants violated the
Fourth and 14th amendments to the
Constitution by racially profiling
Latino motorists and passengers the
Melendez lawsuit which the Justice
Department joined that was Bush's
Justice Department focused primarily on
saturation patrols in 2009 I sma'da fide
its agreement with Arpaio and the
Maricopa camara Copa County Sheriff's
Office revoking their authority to
enforce civil immigration laws except in
jails in 2011 during pretrial
proceedings the district court judge
Anna Marie snow a Bush appointee ruled
in favor of the Melendez plaintiffs on
some of their constitutional claims he
entered a preliminary injunction barring
the defendants from detaining people
solely based on reasonable suspicion
they were unlawfully present in the
country so you can say that this is a
political decision by the judge but it
was really the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals that had already ruled on this
he was abiding by the Ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals ruling so basically the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals said that
he doesn't have the authority Arpaio
does not have the authority to actually
enforce immigration law himself our pyle
disagreed he decided to ignore the
injunction so in 2013 after a non-jury
trial snow concluded that our pyo's
policy violated the fourth and
fourteenth amendments by using race as a
factor in determining where to conduct
patrols in deciding whom to stop and
investigate for civil immigration
violations and in per law
detention of Latinos while their
immigration status was confirmed it was
confirmed
so Arpaio and the NS Co continued to
operate openly acknowledging that they
were violating the law at the time all
of the parties in this particular
lawsuit agreed race cannot be considered
as a factor for reasonable suspicion
that goes all the way back to 1975 and a
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals ruling in
2000 but Sheriff Joe is basically saying
we're not doing on a racial basis we're
rounding people up on the basis of where
we think all the illegal immigrants are
in May 2016 and this is the final
contempt order found 21 days of
evidentiary hearing snow found Arpaio
and other defendants in contempt of
court in 162 page order snow found
Arpaio understood but intentionally
failed to implement the courts
preliminary injunction while publicly
asserting that the MCSO the Maricopa
County Sheriff's Office had the
authority to do what had been enjoined
in the belief that such activities would
benefit his upcoming reelection campaign
so in this in this case our pile
basically openly said I'm ignoring the
law I know I'm ignoring the law and that
was the biggest problem here the
criminal charge carried at least a
minute carried a maximum six-month
sentence it was heard by a Clinton
appointee she rejected our pyo's
argument and she said that he had to go
to jail so I think that Warren Henry's
conclusion here is basically right and I
think this is what we should keep in
mind it's a little more complex than
Trump had no right to pardon our pile
and it's a little more complex than our
piyo was clearly a political victim here
it says for viewing that viewing the
court record and the public record as a
whole
it's easy to argue politics were
involved in the Arpaio case it is less
easy to argue politics played a
significant role or ran in only
direction in only one direction
for example the Obama administration's
termination of our pyo's authority to
enforce civil immigration laws carries
at least a whiff of politics but a key
to snows decision is the judge who made
the contempt decision is that our pyo's
policy of using race as one factor in
assessing reasonable suspicion for
detaining motorists to check illegal
immigration status was largely a
continuation of Isis legal
interpretation of you already rejected
by the Ninth Circuit it could be argued
the Ninth Circuit's precedent which
declined to follow dicta in the Supreme
Court decision was ideological but it
was a decision of the full court and it
wasn't really disputed you could say
that there were politics involved in the
DOJ decision to pursue our paayo for
criminal contempt maybe that's possible
or
they were looking at his case and they
thought that he had openly said that he
was violating the law and engaging in in
some sort of racial profiling so here's
the bottom line if you are sympathetic
to what our pile is doing if you think
that the locals should be able to
enforce immigration law and that there
will be some element that looks like
racial profiling if you are involved in
detaining illegal immigrants in in
Maricopa County then you're likely to
think that this was a political
prosecution if you think that racial
profiling in this case was obvious and
that Sheriff Joe's a bad guy and that he
was attempting to do all these things in
order to help his reelection campaign
then you are likely to think that Trump
is the one whose political here but I
don't think that it's quite as clear as
everybody's making it out to be now
politically is it smart well it's not
smart for the future right politically
it's not it's not it's not brilliant too
you know alienate every Latino voter in
the country by pardoning a guy who is
most famous for saying kind of nasty
things about Latinos generally to
publications like Rolling Stone but
obviously Trump knows where his bases
that's why Trump treated this as sort of
a rallying point right he treated as an
actual rally issue he went to Phoenix
and spoke openly in front of a crowd
about pardoning Sheriff Joe so for Trump
it might be a good move for the
Republican Party in the long run it
probably is a bad move is it
unprecedented no obviously not
President Obama pardoned the pardoned
MHL seam adding President Clinton
pardoned mark rich for obvious political
reasons it's not unprecedented in any
way I've long said I'm an opponent of
the president's ability to pardon I
don't think governors should be able to
pardon I don't think the president
should be able to pardon I don't think
they're granted any godlike knowledge
that is above and beyond what a jury and
a judge can do okay so in other news
affecting the Trump administration Rex
Tillerson looks like he's gonna be on
the way out the Secretary of State I
think that's a good thing I don't think
he's a good Secretary of State I think
the Rex Tillerson is basically a
Democrat I don't think that he is
right-wing in any serious sense he's not
hawkish on foreign policy and any
serious sense he's sort of a State
Department lifer the talk is that he may
be foul stood and nikki Haley would be
made Secretary of State that would be
fantastic
that'd be a fantastic move good for
Trump if he does that Rex Tillerson
basically signed his own death warrants
on the way out he went after Trump
himself he was specifically asked about
Trump's to take on Charlottesville and
here was to larssen's answer and the
president gets into the kind of
controversy he does in the UN
Mette responds the way it does it seems
to say they begin to doubt our whether
we're living those values I don't
believe anyone doubts the American
people's values or the commitment of the
American government or the government's
agencies to advancing those values and
defending those values and and the
president's values the president speaks
for himself Chris okay that's brutal I
mean when your own Secretary of State
won't say that you speak for America's
values that's basically him saying
sayonara I will see you later catch you
on the other side I think the Tillerson
is out by the end of the week I think
that's a good move by the Trump
administration I think it's a bad reason
to oust him you know I think the reason
to oust him is because he's not good at
his job
he's a bad Secretary of State who
doesn't actually forward the policies of
the United States in any serious way but
if he has to go like this I'm in favor
of it fine get out so Tillerson I think
we'll be out I think nikki Haley will
replace him and that would be a good
move by the Trump administration he'll
have to use Haley to replace him because
otherwise the Senate's not gonna confirm
anybody he he nominates Haley has
already gotten through as the own
ambassador it would be hard for the
Senate to turn her down okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like if you
ever want a fantastic synopsis of
various great philosophers overtime will
durant has a book called the story of
philosophy and that truly is a
first-rate book does a great summary of
all of the great philosophers over time
Aristotle and William James and
Nietzsche and an Herbert Spencer and
Plato and Spinoza and Kant it's it's
really terrific it's a great summary of
without having to wade through 800 pages
of a critique of Pure Reason which is
almost unreadable anyway reading their
summary of cons is accurate and Good
Will Durant is of course a very very
famous historian he wrote a much
celebrated history of Western
civilization that is well worth reading
he was he was you know very Pro Western
civilization and it comes out in all of
his writing I believe he's a religious
Catholic so he's a religious thinker as
well it's the this was written in 1926
so it stops dead before you get to a lot
of the later developments in philosophy
but it is quite a it's such a good book
and it's been continuously in print for
years you can for like five bucks on
Amazon it remains an excellent lucid
reading of various
of philosophy after he wrote this and it
came out he wrote the story of
civilization which is like an 11 volume
set that everybody has on their shelf
but nobody who's ever read except me
it's really good it's it's it's really
top-notch so go out and check a story of
civilization as well which is will
Durant's book on the history of Western
civilization okay time for some things
that I hate so let's imagine that we're
in the middle of a natural disaster and
let's imagine that that natural disaster
happened well an unpopular president of
the United States was present and let's
imagine there's some sort of cultural
event where everybody decided to get up
and rip the president in the middle of
that it would never happen for Democrat
but imagine if it happened for Obama
imagine there was a giant hurricane that
put an entire city under water and as
the president was attempting to help
there was a giant cultural event
broadcast on national TV almost solely
dedicated to ripping the presidents of
the United States up and down would you
consider that a problem
would you consider that polarizing I
certainly would that's what the Video
Music Awards were on MTV last night
basically the entire thing was mocking
Trump from beginning to end these I
don't know that these things get any
ratings anymore but they are absolute
turd they're garbage they're most famous
for Miley Cyrus doing whatever her
latest soft porn stick is right whether
she's humping a foam finger with Robin
Thicke or whether she is doing a puppet
show full of sex there's always some
it's basically pushed the boundaries
land in via mail and this is they became
originally I mean the first time I
remember the VMAs becoming a national
issue is when Britney Spears was
strutting around the stage with the
giant boa constrictor
about her abdomen but that is but
they've moved on from there now they've
decided to go full political so Paris
Jackson who I don't even know why Paris
Jackson is culturally relevant Michael
Jackson's daughter I guess has she ever
been genetically tested but because I
think they said it was artificial
insemination correct in Paris Jackson I
believe was the case in any case Paris
Jackson mocked Trump during the VMAs for
no apparent reason
I'm you've seen a lot of love and light
here tonight already
a lot of diversity and a lot of
potential power you know if we were to
all put our voices together do you
realize the difference we would make if
we were to all stand up United as one
our impact it would be huge
believe me huge and that's not fake news
so let's leave here tonight remembering
that we must show these Nazi white
supremacist jerks the country as a
nation with liberty as our slogan we
have zero tolerance for their violence
their hatred and
so she's so racist oh preach it Paris
I mean she's that she's at legitimately
one of the most useless cultural events
in history a bunch of people whose music
will be forgotten inside of two years
with a bunch of young kids who have
nothing better to do than spend their
night listening to a bunch of adult
celebrities talk to them about things of
which they know nothing and then she
gets to feel real special because we all
hate Nazis whoo guess what I've been
hating Nazis my whole life we fought a
war to kill a bunch of Nazis okay well
everybody hates the Nazis you're not
doing anything special by saying we hate
Nazis yeah we all hate Nazis yeah how
about if she got up
imagine a Paris Jackson and gotten up
and say listen violence is never the
answer on any side I shouldn't say that
right should we have to stand up to
their violence and their hatred and
their bigotry as people of Liberty we
cannot tolerate their hate well I'm
pretty certain that as people of Liberty
you have to tolerate their hate so long
as it's not violent is one of the
principles of Liberty because what you
consider hate might be somebody else's
belief system and you can tell that I
highly doubt that Paris Hilton or Paris
Jackson actually feels the necessity to
limit her own hatred for Nazis alone
because the left never does left always
broadens it out right when I go to
Berkeley in two and a half weeks they're
gonna call me a Nazi they will okay
they'll call me a Nazi because this is
what they do and then they'll get up and
they'll say we couldn't tolerate him it
was so great to identify shut him down
because he was just like a Nazi you know
why because he says the black lives
matter is not a movement that helps the
country that's like a Nazi you know who
would say that Hitler Hitler would say
that you know used to you at the fork
Hitler like that this routine is really
getting old but the level of I would
let's pat ourselves on the back because
we hate Nazis guess what you know what I
don't feel like a better person because
I hate Nazis that's my basic principle
as a human being
I don't feel like a better human because
I dislike you no all right white
supremacists I don't feel like a better
human being because that's just like
being a normal human I don't spend my
time virtue signaling because virtually
signaling is not virtue but this is just
virtue signaling B's you're not actually
doing anything you're not actually like
how many people in the audience are like
you know what I was a Nazi one second
ago but now that Paris Jackson said that
I guess I'm gonna give up my hatred and
my violence I'm not not two anymore
because of Paris Jackson so so
ridiculous Katy Perry who looks like the
nice clean-cut daughter who you sent off
to school and she came back a lesbian
dance theory major she
decided that it was worthwhile to mock
Trump as well first of all Katy Perry
doesn't get to mock anybody's hair with
this getup I mean she looks like she she
stuck her head in a bowling ball cleaner
here is Katy Perry so there are five
nominees for Best New Artist when this
whole night got started now it's just up
to the top two congratulations Julian
Michaels and Kelleen will join the ranks
of other Best New Artist winners like
Justin Bieber Lady gaga and my personal
favorite putting the Blowfish
listen guys this is one election where
the popular vote actually matters so
vote online
but hurry up before some random Russian
popstar wins okay okay so boring so
stupid Katy Perry should not do comedy
but here's my advice to the Democrats
please keep using Katy Perry and
everything you did it at the DNC it
worked beautifully ensuring that Hillary
Clinton would never be President of the
United States okay this one I thought
was you know I feel bad for Heather
hires mom Heather hires mom showed up to
the VMAs I do not know why Heather hires
moms at the VMAs
Heather hire was of course the victim of
the white supremacists in
Charlottesville the woman who was killed
was Heather hire her mom shows up at the
VMAs I do not like that like I can't
speak Heather hires mom can do whatever
she wants right I haven't lost a child I
can't speak to that if somebody did that
to my child the chances that I would go
on a cultural show to talk about it like
this like a VMA type show are know it
would not happen and the reason it would
not happen is because this is obviously
just a it's it's a stupid it's a stupid
show and for the VMAs to use the
platform as a let's let's make it about
Charlotte's ville again 95% of Americans
hate white supremacist probably 98% of
Americans hate white supremacist is all
virtue signaling in an attempt to
suggest that anybody who doesn't like
the VMAs lifestyle and VMA is a lot more
than just we don't like Nazis it's an
attempt to say anybody who dislikes the
VMAs generally must stand against the in
must stand against the the anti-nazi
routine here's Heather hires mom
presenting an award the VMAs I don't see
the purpose of this for the VMAs I don't
see the purpose of this for Heather
hires mom again she can do what you want
I have nothing but but sympathy for
Heather hires mom but this seems to me a
mistake in terms of bringing in the
countries together as opposed to
polarizing it it is my distinct honor to
introduce Susan bro Heather hires mother
whose continuing to magnify Heather's
work
we all
and this has been true for years it's
not specific to have the hires mouth I
have a general objection to in politics
using people who are victims of crime as
spokespeople for a particular point of
view I don't like it very much the
reason being that if we're going to
espouse particular policies they should
be disconnected from emotion they
shouldn't be connected deeply to emotion
I understand in politics the easy thing
is to always connect it to emotion
ifit's you can't watch this woman and I
feel horrible for her obviously what
happens her daughter was an evil evil
crime and the person who did it should
get the death penalty but I don't
understand what it has to do with Video
Music Awards I think that the more we
meld our culture and our politics the
more polarizing both culture and
politics become okay we will be back
here tomorrow we'll bring you all of the
latest two updates including an Tifa
updates of which I'm sure there will be
many plus just want to mention before I
go here they Berkeley still has not
released tickets for my event in on
September 14th but if you go to yaf dot
org yaf dot org then we set up a link
where you can sign up for a list so you
will be the first to be notified about
the availability of tickets I think
there are 2,000 tickets available we
already have like 1600 signups in just
about 48 hours here so the tickets are
going really fast in terms of people who
are signing up some notifies who go over
to Yap and sign up to be notified wanna
make sure that we packed the hall this
is a free speech event and we are gonna
be speaking out against tribalism all
the things we talk about on the show
will come up so it should be a great
event and I look forward to seeing you
there obviously everyone will mate
nonviolent we are paying so that the
police will do their jobs I'm a taxpayer
in the state of California so the police
will do their jobs you're a taxpayer in
the United States so the police should
do their jobs go back here tomorrow i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
you